Так зароджується нове життя. Дитина.
Яйцеклітина жінки ділиться вперше через 30 годин
після запліднення у лабораторії.
А через п'ять днів ця яйцеклітина вводиться у жіночу матку.
Усе це відбувається в клініці, що знаходиться
в центрі Берліна у престижному районі.
Сюди приходять жінки, які не можуть завагітніти природним шляхом.
Керівник клініки Петер Зюдов, перш за все,
має вказати на високу вартість процедури.
Німецька медична страховка покриває лише половину витрат.
Здебільшого відбувається так, що пари кажуть: ми знаємо,
це коштує 2000 євро, ми вже назбирали гроші на одну спробу, дві чи три.
Таким чином тема високої вартості, яка дуже непокоїть людей,
- не є найважливішою для тих, хто вже прийшов до нас і визначився.
Потрібні великі зусилля для штучного запліднення.
Під час операції під загальним наркозом у жінки беруться яйцеклітини,
активність яких раніше була підсилена гормональними препаратами.
Чим молодша жінка, тим кращі перспективи таки завагітніти.
Більшості пацієнток - понад 35 років.
Наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб ізолювати яйцеклітини
і побачити ембріони, які несуть із собою
максимально високий шанс на успішну вагітність.
І тут нам дуже допомагають сучасні медичні технології –
це камери, генетичні перевірки, які уможливлюють
виявлення здорових ембріонів, а також
зменшення ризику обривання вагітності.
За допомогою високотехнологічних камер лікарі визначають яйцеклітини,
подібні до ось цих, які не призведуть до народження дитини.
Одна з ознак цього: клітини збираються докупи.
Це унеможливлює штучне запліднення.
Клініка Петера Зюдова входить до групи
медзакладів у чотирьох європейських країнах.
Загалом приблизно 25 тисяч пацієнтів щороку.
Адже дедалі більше жінок хочуть мати дітей пізніше.
Часто це можливо лише за допомогою репродуктивної медицини.
Минулого року кількість успішних випадків
штучного запліднення значно збільшилась.
Якщо ми усі можливості, які має репродуктивна медицина,
використовуємо, то виходить сукупний показник вагітності
від 65 до 80 відсотків, тобто тих, хто нарешті
повертається додому з дитиною.
Це для нас дуже і дуже гарний показник.
Ста відсотків ми ніколи не досягнемо.
Завжди є пари, які, незважаючи на усі зусилля і повторні спроби,
на жаль, не можуть досягти вагітності.
Разом з цим набуває популярності послуга
консервування здорових яйцеклітин молодих жінок.
Це допомагає їм завагітніти у більш зрілому віці.
Яйцеклітини розморожують, запліднюють - і жінки стають мамами.